let's see who's going to get me more
thanks
[Laughter]
that's new broncos gm george payton
ending a call when some trade talks
apparently were happening and that's the
way to do it hey i don't like what
you're offering i'm going to get more
from someone else now he needs all he
can get if he's going to
eventually be in the running sharing for
aaron rodgers i was told last week on
thursday when this was all blowing up
that rogers wish list 49ers raiders
broncos and the momentum has pointed
toward the broncos even though there
were no negotiations at all between the
broncos and the packers for that ninth
overall pick in the draft i really do
think if a trade happens it's going to
be a post june 1 transaction to lessen
the cap hit that the green bay packers
would take and if i'm a team that wants
aaron rodgers i can wait 31 more days to
get actually it's 30 days june 2 is 30
days from may 3 31 days in may i can
wait to get aaron rodgers on june 2. but
it's caused the
the betting world to take notice the
folks at points bet have removed both
the packers and the broncos but not the
raiders from the over under win total
proposition so they're off the board
because
they clearly think something could be up
that would affect the packers win totals
and the broncos win totals and the only
thing obviously that would affect both
is a trade that would send rogers from
green bay to denver
and you look at the broncos super bowl
odds mike they've gone from 60 to one
before all the aaron rodgers trade talk
at one point today i think they hit or
one point over the last few days they
hit 13 to one something like that and
now i think it's somewhere around 20 to
one last time i checked so their super
bowl odds also have changed so there is
some feeling that maybe aaron rodgers
ends up in denver and how wild would
that be mike if they went on and won a
super bowl with aaron rodgers after in
winning one with peyton manning at the
end of his career that would be pretty
unbelievable to have john elway peyton
manning and aaron rodgers have won super
bowls for you i know that's a long way
down the road the trade hasn't even
happened yet but it would be an amazing
feat to have all those quarterbacks
having played for your team
and
when you think about the fact that aaron
rodgers is only a year older
than peyton manning was when manning
became the broncos quarterback and
manning was
basically being held together by duct
tape and glue at that point rogers
physically is fine he's got four years
left in him i mean that's what
manning gave the broncos four seasons
but it was four spectacular seasons and
they would do it again if they could and
they may be able to do it the only
difference is they got peyton manning
for nothing and it was only an 18
million contract which was not top of
the market at the time
but to have to trade something
significant that that really
becomes the question there's so many
parallels between this and the texans
because once the packers accept the fact
that they are going to have to trade him
if they do accept it they don't play
hardball what are they gonna want what
are they gonna get two first round picks
three first round picks what's aaron
rodgers worth at this stage of his
career when you look at what the 49ers
gave up to move from 12 to three to get
a guy maybe they would have gotten if
they'd stayed at 12 anyway they at least
would have gotten
one of the three guys that they were
exploring when they moved up to number
three they could have stayed where they
were but they gave up those extra two
first rounders for that when you look at
that what value a quarterback has
it it uh it becomes interesting to see
what the broncos ultimately would do
and it would give the packers
some assurance they wouldn't have to
worry about dealing with aaron rodgers
the way they would if he stayed in the
conference and and that's one of the
factors
get him out of the conference just like
it was with brett favre get him out of
the conference
and even though as peter king pointed
out today
we would lose the patrick holmes aaron
rodgers game this year and it would and
it is complicating the nfl's effort to
make a schedule of games because one of
the best games of the season may go up
in smoke it gives you two
mahomes and rogers games if he lands
with the broncos so as you plan the
schedule you need to factor in the
possibility that we could double
this intrigue and maybe both broncos
chiefs games get get held for later in
the season maybe one gets put in prime
time and the other one gets put at 4 25
eastern because they both could end up
being extremely compelling if this does
happen
think about all the things that aaron
rodgers has complicated might you talk
about the betting market we've talked
about the nfl scheduled he's he's
unsettled packers fans he's unsettled
matt lafleur that was a pretty great
quote that he gave over the weekend
about can you imagine aaron rodgers not
wanting to play for your team and
suiting up for somebody else next year
so he's complicated a lot of things in
the nfl right now mike and all anyone is
talking about is aaron rodgers where's
his future where is he gonna go is he
gonna come back to the packers and and
this is not gonna end it doesn't look
like anytime soon mike so this could
extend out another month two months
however long it takes
for the packards to some come to some
conclusion about aaron rodgers future
i think he loves every minute of it
frankly and i think that he and his camp
will strategically continue to leak
information
to keep the fire burning just another
log on it here another log on it there
because it serves as an irritant to the
packers and eventually that
next log could be the one that gets mark
murphy to say let's just be done with it
or creates some sort of a ground swell i
talked about it today you got murphy you
got six other people on the executive
committee you got 40 people on the board
of directors you know it's not like the
shareholders can band together and have
an emergency vote
to trade or keep aaron rodgers or do
whatever you have to do to keep aaron
rodgers so i just think that the more
that he can irritate the packers
management
all it takes is one day that they say
let's just be done with this
we're sick of it we accept it
and we're going to move on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports